[Applause]
this is so cool
[Applause]
[Music]
can I get you all to smile for a selfie
I'm gonna get one too I just I want to
take a panorama I think this is the only
circumstance will ever be sitting in
this position in a room like this
actually when she does that everybody
when you're ready
everybody wave and you're on c-span to
wave this is so ho great use of time
yeah Kate eat all right thank you yeah
by the way how many of you use the
hashtag I'm with turn check it out how
did that feel that hashtag and all that
reception just now oh really amazing
overwhelming undeserved it's surreal
exciting well I don't know I mean at the
undeserved part let's review your
foreign correspondent when NBC assigned
you to be the first and for a long time
only correspondent assigned to follow
the Trump campaign both neophytes as you
told me there'd be those infamous now
moments long before President Trump
referred to senator bob Corker as little
bob Corker you were a little Katie he
got two DS though yes slightly different
two T's a huge rally back in that
fenced-in area where the Trump campaign
kept reporters so it was sort of like
indicating to the rabid dogs where the
meat was there you were in the cage you
know little Katie she's back there she's
such a liar what a liar she is unheard
of in the history of American politics
it's no secret that politicians don't
like reporters
generally Nixon had a fraught
relationship with his press corps there
are legendary stories about Ron Ziegler
his press person and getting into it
with reporters what was unusual about
this was the very public nature of it
the way that he would go after reporters
myself included from the stage of
rallies and have the crowd encouraged
the crowd to essentially turn on us
boo us there were moments where I spoke
to somebody on the campaign late in the
campaign and after we had armed security
after I'd gotten death threats after not
only NBC provided armed security but so
did ABC and so did CNN and during the
height of the CNN suck stuff as well I
said does he know that he's potentially
putting us in real harm's way and danger
that something really bad could happen
and the person said yes he knows and I
said does he care and he said I don't
think he cares why do you think it was
but you and that you in particular we're
so singled out I mean from the very
first interview 2015 New Hampshire not
interview but very first rally and 2015
he said something about and the
television reporters are here and
there's Katie turn she's not even
looking at me yeah so that was I mean
that was the first time we'd ever shared
the same era I didn't know Donald Trump
I knew him from television I knew him
from The Apprentice I knew him from the
New York tabloids from the birtherism
crusade not as a as a serious political
candidate and I had no reason to believe
that he knew who I was so I'm standing
in the back of this rally which was just
a couple hundred people who had a
backyard pool thinking what the heck am
I doing here
and what the heck is this guy talking
about because he was you know talking
about the wall that he was gonna build
and defending his comments about Mexico
sending rapists
he was then alternating between that and
how he gets more standing ovations and
anybody and then how the press is
terrible and Oh Katie you haven't even
looked up at me once and I'm like who
the cocky and he was and I remember just
screaming right back at him you know I'm
tweeting what you're saying and he liked
that said I did a good job and then he
continued on that's important he said
well I hope so and by the way you do a
good job yeah you know I'm when I read
over these again in the book which is
terrific and you all have to get it and
get it signed afterwards but when I was
reading back all over it in the current
climate
of Harvey Weinstein and also since these
comments yelled at you we've had the
tape of the Donald Trump Billy Bush tape
talking about grabbing women's lady
parts reading over these comments now in
this climate this feels like sexual
harassment from the stage well he went
after all reporters it wasn't just
female reporter but you know Tommy ah
missus sleaze yeah and it well you know
talked about Charles Krauthammer not
being able to get a pair of pants this
was in an interview with you and of
course he's in a wheelchair so there's
that but no with you there seems to be
something have you thought about it what
there's some sort of power play going on
there's a power play going on I was
doing my job
and he alternated between trying to
charm me and trying to bully me if I
wasn't reporting what he liked he would
go on the attack and the offensive from
the stage if I reported something he did
like he would tell everyone how great I
was try to introduce me to an entire
crowd at a rally once as something like
the great Katy tur he kissed me on the
cheek one morning when he liked my
reporting at a Morning Joe town hall and
then went on to brag about it on
television which is unusual i but at the
same time that's that what he does to
this day when he's sitting with his
counterparts in the Republican Party I
mean he will have Dean Heller sitting
next to him at a cabinet in the cabinet
meeting a Senate meeting and you know
joke around with him not so jokingly to
say that you know if you don't do what I
say I'm gonna I'm gonna go after you
when it comes to the health care vote he
that's just the way he operates to
ascribe a certain other label to it I'm
just not prepared to do it yeah what
about Trump supporters because I we have
questions by the way that we're
submitted by many of you and I'm gonna
try to work in as many as I can
without dropping all of these papers and
you know obviously you people turned on
you you need
support you or spit at you would see
families what look like lovely families
but wait look closer the dad's wearing a
t-shirt that says Hillary sucks more
than Monica does but it's not like but
not like Monica and you'd be taken aback
by wait a second there's they've got
small children with them that wasn't
even the worst I mean there was that
then there was the father with his two
kids and his wife proudly wearing a
shirt that called Hillary Clinton a cont
there was a man who wore a shirt that
said I wish Hillary married Oh Jay I
don't care what your political beliefs
are I don't care if you think Democrats
have all the wrong ideas for this
country if you think Republicans have
all the wrong ideas for this country
that was a shirt that said I hoped
essentially that Hillary Clinton was
brutally stabbed to death in the 1990s I
mean that is that is so far beyond what
should be acceptable for common decency
for behavior let alone politics but do
you think I mean you got to know the
Trump supporters and people and their
might you know their this is Boston but
I'm sure there are many in this room and
faith wrote to ask you spoke about
running into a Trump supporter in the
bathroom before a rally who helped you
with your hair an act of kindness it's
it's you can't paint an entire group of
supporters with a broad brush I mean
think it's a mistake to call I think I
thought it was a huge mistake to call
Donald Trump supporters deplorable I
don't think that's that you should you
don't go after voters in this country
and I don't think it's a good idea to
say that this swath of voters are all a
bunch of racists xenophobes misogynist
so you know whatever name you want to
ascribe to them they are a varied group
of people from a number of different
socioeconomic backgrounds they have they
some of them voted for President Obama
in the past a lot of them were women I
mean there there are a variety of
supporters and at the same time they
were the kind of people who oftentimes
would probably live their lives in a
very polite and you know rule-abiding
way not of non offensive way but there
was something about walking into a Trump
rally
that allowed people to shed all of those
rules to shed those burdens that I write
in the book that Trump had a halo of
crudeness and in that hail in that halo
of crudeness he allowed everybody else
to be crude around him he said whatever
he wanted he never backed down and a lot
of people found that refreshing people
who maybe couldn't tell a joke any
longer because it was a politically
incorrect joke people who were worried
that they had to watch what they said
and watch what they did people who
thought that their patriotism was being
mistaken for racism and they walked in
there and they said I can I can say and
do whatever I'm thinking we talked
earlier about covering the primaries and
very early on I was in Iowa and you
could see the lines at the Trump rally
there and was calling back to WV you are
and saying yeah I'm meeting a lot of
young people in particular young men in
particular who are trying to decide
between Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump
a certain bro culture that would come
out to the Trump rallies men who would
wear tank tops and you know big make
America great again hats that that
college fraternity culture that would
show up and really like the enthusiasm
of the event the same sort of people who
would you know say I want to vote for
and this is a kind of a broad brush I
have to apologize but this is a
demographic that I'm talking about
really liked either Bernie Sanders or
like Donald Trump and it was because
they wanted an outsider they wanted
somebody different somebody refreshing
somebody who wasn't part of the
establishment somebody who whose name
they hadn't been hearing their whole
life like Hillary Clinton somebody who
wasn't afraid to take on the system
Bernie Sanders had that quality as so
did Donald Trump and they both had jobs
messages I mean these are young people
who are either just in the the search
they're just in the middle of a search
for a job or soon to be graduating from
college and they wanted a better
opportunity they wanted a disrupter to
definitely want a disrupter do you think
and I thought I observed this that
I constantly saw people who saw things
that people on the Left might see as
appalling like those t-shirts you
mentioned and they thought they were a
perfectly acceptable parallel reality of
what they might have seen for instance
when George Bush george w bush the
invasion of iraq and there were so many
people who were against that and you if
you went if you'd gone to the anti-war
rally in washington you would have seen
people wearing very disparaging t-shirts
about george bush yeah and they really
felt it was the same yeah and there's an
argument to be made for for that i think
that's just a sign of how corrosive our
politics and our public discourse has
become it's it's the question is where
does it go from here do we do we correct
it does it get better for 2024 2024 or
are we going to see even more crude
language crude behavior is there gonna
be a line that that is too far a bridge
too far where do we go do you feel
somewhat validated in your reporting
that we now have a president Trump who
hasn't really changed his style he's 71
years old he's never gonna change this
is who he is the guy you saw on the
campaign trail is the guy that you see
in the Oval Office every day he just
yesterday made a and he would make these
broad statements on the campaign trail
like I saw thousands of Muslims cheering
on the streets of New Jersey after the
towers came down not true didn't happen
and then he forced his campaign staff to
try and find evidence to bolster him so
they're running around and and trying to
find anything that might that might
point to some shred of truth in that
statement yesterday he did you can't
it's not true yesterday he did the same
thing which was saying that past
presidents including President Obama
didn't call the families of fallen
soldiers that is not true but he said it
he's put it out there people are gonna
want to believe it they will believe in
and what does the White House do they
run in circles to try and find something
that
that backs them up that bolsters them
and what they found was chief of staff
John Kelly President Obama didn't call
him while he was at a number of events
with Obama that we're honoring fallen
soldiers and Kelly's a gold star always
killed exactly and but what they've done
now and this is what's sad about this
beyond politics beyond Donald Trump
beyond whatever you may think about
Republicans or Democrats what's sad
about this is we're now politicizing the
death of John Kelly's son that's awful
that shouldn't be happening right now
we already politicized gold star
families exactly what happened during
the campaign responds by the way general
Kelly Brighton Zone I just want to say
he's from Brighton so what should the
press do we have a question here about
let's see I want I'm sorry Matt these
papers about whether or not somebody
suggests the press should boycott you
can't boycott the President of the
United States yeah I'm sorry I mean you
might not like him but that's not what
we do in this country
yeah he's the democratically elected
president the United States and so there
is a we have a service to everybody in
this room and to everybody in in this
land to cover the president else it it
affects you every single day you have to
cover it Lauren asked you know should
journalists boycott White House
briefings as a sign of solidarity for
his lack of respect for First Amendment
rights and press accountability that's
the dropping to the knees
well what you do what you do if that
happens and until you boycott the press
briefings you just you just validate
Donald Trump's complaints that the press
corps is out to get him that they're not
on his side they're looking for any
reason to not report on the things that
he's doing it's it's a double-edged
sword in that way well and Barry also
asks from what you saw on the trail do
you think the president intentionally
attacked the credibility of the press to
rally his base is it just a technique or
is he really hurt you know some have
suggested that when he lashes out like
this for instance in the question
yesterday and what got completely
obscured is that four soldiers were
killed in Nazaire
most Americans don't know why yeah and
we still aren't talking about that
because the question now becomes whether
or not President Obama also or did not
you know it's it's it's a lie everything
gets clouded it just makes things cloudy
or he is very capable of distracting
everything comes around it's always
about him how does it make him look how
does it affect him what does he need to
do about something it's not about the
death of the the soldiers it's about
what has he done or what has he done in
in separation from his predecessors
every every policy every subject every
interview every topic it all goes back
to him he uses AI so much the disaster
response during the Hurricanes the
governor called to say I was doing a
good job the FEMA director under Clinton
called to say I did a good job it's me
me me me me what was the the first part
of the question I'm sorry I just lost my
train of thought is all about you you
know is this owed zeal a shout is it is
it to do that to distract us or do you
feel this something that he's genuinely
I think it's both I think it's both I
think he likes to dominate the headlines
and on days we would see this during the
the campaign on days where he was and
main focus in the headline they were few
and far between he would make sure that
he he took it over I mean the the Muslim
Band day is a perfect example of this
the day before President Obama had given
a speech on terrorism so the day was
being dominated by that speech by the
President and then Donald Trump
announces a Muslim ban recaptures a
narrative for that day and then he wants
to be liked he really wants to be liked
he wants to be accepted there's a chip
on his shoulder that's been there since
he was a young man in Queens crossing
the river to start making our building
skyscrapers in Manhattan his father said
he could never do it and he was trying
to prove him wrong but he was never
really accepted by the you know the the
ruling class if you will of Manhattan so
he's always been trying to prove himself
and that's why with
reporters he'll be extremely friendly at
first and very charming because he wants
reporters to like him just like and
anyone who would you if you meet him in
person he's a very charming person he's
very nice he wants you to like him
Katy tur I won't ask you a little bit
about yourself and again I have to
shuffle here a little bit but you're
family you were born into the news biz
your parents bob and marie cutter was an
understatement I was I was born while my
parents were covering a breaking news
story I mean it's true for those who
don't know
bobdor marie cutter i legendary in los
angeles you know them without knowing
that you know them they changed the face
of local news and as you write maybe not
for the better your dad a gutsy teenage
runaway you write a big mouth and a
bigger ambition your mom from a more
stable family but she fell in love with
journalism post-watergate they teamed up
they had a small news service in LA
chasing you know gang fights or fires
and things car accident car accidents
yeah there were stringers yeah it's
meant that they would go out in the
middle of the night and cover news
stories when the local news didn't have
cameramen out and then they would sell
it to the morning shows and the
afternoon shows in the day and they
built up a business with that bought a
helicopter at one point there was a big
strike in LA all the cameramen and the
news teams were on strike but your
parents they didn't physically cross a
picket line but they essentially lower
where they were scabs they didn't have
the helicopter at that time they did it
because my mom was pregnant with my
brother I was two years old and my dad
had this ambition to be a helicopter
journalist and to cover Los Angeles from
the skies la is a big place you need a
helicopter to get around and he had this
really big idea and he walked into one
helicopter company and they laughed him
out I mean he was 24 at the time or yeah
24 at the time and he had 30 grand in
his pocket and the helicopter at that
point costs 250 grand and then the
second the second helicopter company
said okay well we'll give this to you
and they bought it and became since at
least at least it became sensations they
changed everything I mean suddenly
everything was up in the sky they were
doing these car chases and then you know
Bob and Marie couture became the people
behind the famous video of Reginald
Denny being pulled from his truck during
the LA riots when you hear that sound
saying oh my god they're beating they're
trying to kill they're trying to kill
him that's your dad
and then the white Bronco and the person
in the helicopter chasing the white
Bronco and you hear his voice is bobbed
her and was your mom my mom was the
camera woman cam she was hanging at this
time she was hanging out of the
helicopter with it with it she gets none
of the credit and I feel so bad for her
because she was literally hanging out of
the helicopter with the with a beta cam
on her shoulder which is like a 70 pound
camera just literally hanging nothing
between her and and the ground but air
and she had a canvas strap that was
hooking her into harness that hooked her
into the helicopter and she did that
over fires she did it over floods she
did that over police pursuit she did
that over riots and at one point during
the LA riots while they were covering
the Reginald Denny beating the gang
members were shooting up at the
helicopter when they landed the mechanic
said that there was bullet damage in the
engine blades and there was bullet
damage in the battery the camera battery
that she stowed beneath her seat your
parents are amazing I'm sorry I mean I
really I was you know covering the riots
and you know when I put that together
turn there alters it's not very many
turrets right it just and you grew up
with this you there's video of you as
you write in your book at four years old
doing your own little news reporting
with your dad making up news stories
covering fires they used to buzz you in
the playground at school
you hum out of that hell
after I did I did there was one I did
not have a harness on either there was
one instance and my poor father almost
had a heart attack in the middle of this
where we were over the Rose Parade in
Los Angeles and my dad was doing live
reports for the radio at the time and he
brought me up and I was a very savvy kid
figured out how to open the helicopter
door it's not easy it's pretty
complicated you have to pull down pull
out and then pull to the side and I did
it as a four-year-old because I wanted
to get a better look at the floats below
and my dad remember is looking back and
very calmly because he was cool under
pressure
saying Katie please sit down I can bar
the doors he reaches back he pulled the
door shut and then he said he
immediately had to to land the
helicopter because he thought he was
going to pass out yeah I mean it was a
wonderful life for a long time Porsches
and trips to Hawaii I mean your parents
became very successful that they were it
changed at a certain point they were not
successful they were losing the
helicopter and it seemed to spiral out
want to talk about that but you even
when it was they were at the height you
this didn't appeal to you journalism
didn't appeal to you there wasn't that
that's not the story no I mean it was it
just seems so disruptive in our lives I
am a terrible eater I have to try to
remind myself when I'm out with my now
fiancé to eat like a lady because I
attendants they just stuff food in my
face because when I was a kid we would
be in the middle of a meal and there
would something would come over the
scanners and we'd have to just stop what
we were doing and get in the helicopter
and cover it I mean they lived story to
story my mom used to sleep with a
scanner in her ear it was it was a
disruptive lifestyle there was no
stability to it and I just my dad would
put a camera in my face all the time and
I just had no desire to do to be in
front of it I would run in the opposite
direction but you were a teenager too
what changed
I mean I can't deny your genes I guess I
was gonna be I wanted to be a doctor but
I got I think I got a D in chemistry I
was terrible at it really bad at math
and then I I changed my major to
philosophy and I was gonna go to law
school and I sat down with one of the
counselors that in my last year of
college and she said you need this score
to get into UCLA on the LSAT and I and I
just said I just don't want to study any
longer I wasn't feeling it and I was
driving back to school one one weekend
with my with my boyfriend at the time my
college boyfriend and there was a fire
in Malibu I went to UC Santa Barbara
lived in Los Angeles so you drove up PCH
and there was a cut-off because there
was a fire in Malibu and my dad even
after the the business fell apart kept
making me fake press passes and this one
he took he took my photo and he and he
and he post put it over my photo of my
grandmother who was in the business with
my family and then real Amman ated it
and so that was my press pass it's a
felony by the way I don't know if you
know that I didn't at the time or I
certainly would not have done this next
thing I pulled up to the sheriff's
officer who was he was guarding in the
line and I showed him my press pass and
I said my crews up ahead I'd like to go
in and and see the fire and I'm sure he
knew it was fake I mean it was so
obviously fake but he let me through and
my boyfriend looked at me and he said I
have never seen you more confident than
you were just then lying to that officer
and I thought you know I I'm always I'm
always chasing ambulances I'm always
curious about what's behind that crime
tape I want to be in the know I can't
deny it any longer I'm gonna I'm gonna
go into the news business I told my
parents it did not go well
because I didn't want you to do it they
don't want me to at this point you know
so when I was fourteen KCBS undercut all
of their all of their staff and reach
their contract and the whole business
fell apart and my parents fell apart
because of it they had Porsches and we
went on Hawaiian vacations but because
they we did all that they never put any
money into a bank account so we didn't
really save so when the business fell
apart the family kind of fell apart and
when I told my my dad specifically that
I was going and going into it he was
angry he felt like he had been
victimized he didn't feel like the the
news business was a good place to be
he's the one that wanted to meet me to
be a doctor or a lawyer because it was
so much more stable and we got into a
giant argument and he basically said
you're gonna end up you know asking do
you want fries with that for a living
and I slammed my slammed the door in his
face in my apartment and we didn't talk
for a week well and apparently there was
some further estrangement you can you
can clarify because your parents were
divorced and ten years later your father
Bob tour transitioned and became so
eater and yep and if you see the Oh Jay
made an American documentary it's now a
woman she's great in it she is fantastic
is great in it how difficult was that
for you or how obviously it's a
difficult situation I mean no we didn't
see it coming
it's hard it's it's hard when when a
parent changes so drastically but my dad
is an incredibly brave person and she's
always been an incredibly brave person a
boundary defier and a rule-breaker
that's the way it's
it's always been the instrument is is
difficult it's long-standing I mean the
you can see a glimpse of it of when I
decided to go to the news business it's
not a complete estrangement we we talk
but it's hard it's hard it's hard my
family's uh complicated but I am really
really proud of the decision that she
made and I think that it takes a lot of
guts to do that we could do a whole hour
on that could you not but you make it
clear in your book that your dad is as
you say big mouth you know outspoken in
fact you say at one point when you're in
one of the exchanges with Donald Trump
the candidate hey you can deal with this
because you had this dad you help
everybody I have these very
larger-than-life figures in my life that
I've grown up with and arguments the
dinner table were a normal thing
everybody had very strong opinions and
that the way that Donald Trump sometimes
it just it was wasn't unfamiliar let's
put it that way and it was a good it was
a good primer for for standing up to
people later in life and but that's my
whole family we're all kind of like that
my mom my brother my dad my uncle's my
aunts we all we all have have big loud
mouths and we all like to yell at each
other over Thanksgiving dinner table
we'd love to be a fly on that wall I
Tony my fiance's here he's gonna have to
deal with that for the next foreseeable
future I'm sorry wherever you are back
to Donald Trump have you had any
interaction with him does it did he
respond to the book he sub tweeted me it
was very exciting he said something
along the lines of fascinating to see
people who have zero access to me right
major articles and published major books
I had just done an article for the New
York Times and I and then he said zero
access which is kind of his codeword for
me he always likes to say that I have
zero
but you had sit down I hope sit down I
have a lot of excess but here's the
thing about Donald Trump you don't need
an any politician you don't need access
access is not it's not how you do
journalism you you dig and you and you
fact check and you contextualize and you
you try to shed light on the person and
you don't need access to do that access
journalism is fairly journalism and he
is so public as it is the idea of
needing access to cover him is it's a
bit laughable yeah or any public figure
for that matter well what would you
where are we now and where do you think
Trump supporters are now are you still
in contact with the many you met and as
yeah you said acts of kindness for many
dr. McCormick was telling us that there
are many Trump supporters who come here
to this Institute because they feel that
I hope I'm quoting you correctly they
feel that while they support their guy
they elected someone to be a disruptor
they never thought he understood
government that wasn't why they elected
him and now they are coming here to
learn more about government so they can
help him if you've got yes but what are
you hearing we know that the the polls
show there's some softening there's some
softening well it depends on who you ask
there are some that that volunteered for
Trump that are still very enthusiastic
about him some folks up in New Hampshire
that I talked to regularly there is a
gentleman down in South Carolina who
would show up at every Trump rally that
he would hold enthusiastically there
love Donald Trump thought he was
wonderful thought he was a disrupter
thought that he would bring change is
horrified and appalled at the the
president that he's become part of what
he doesn't like about it is the attacks
on the press he thinks that that is just
way overboard and not helpful for
anything but there is a there is an idea
that that people elected Donald Trump
because they thought he he would be
throwing a bomb into the system he
might not know everything about policy
he might not know the ins and outs of
health care or the ins and outs of
Veterans Affairs but he will hire the
right people to do the jobs and I would
ask you why they believe that about him
and a lot of the time the answer I would
get and don't laugh when I say this is I
saw him do it on the apprentice I told
her not to laugh but it's it's part of
Donald Trump has created a mythology
around himself
and he's always done that since he got
on to the real estate scene the tabloid
scene in New York in the 1970s 1980s
he's he has been selling Donald Trump
he's not a real estate mogul
he's a branding mogul he doesn't build
buildings generally he puts his name on
buildings his name he sells himself he
sells the image of success he sells the
image of a deal maker he goes out and
he'll say over and over again I alone
can fix this
I can make deals nobody else can this is
a terrible deal I will make it better a
deal deal deal deal deal he thought that
word is I think the most loved word and
his vocabulary and he and he is
successful at it he's but he's always
been successful at it it wasn't just
Donald Trump's supporters it was the
reporters in New York and the 90s in the
80s Jimmy Breslin wrote about this early
on for Newsday in in New York and he
this was around the time that Donald
Trump was on the verge of financial
collapse when he was going through his
bankruptcies he was to use a cliche
cliche hanging on by a thread and people
were starting to say Oh Donald Trump's
gonna fail and breslin came out an
article and said how could you say that
Donald Trump will it will create a
razzle dazzle he'll call all the
reporters in New York and say if Donald
Trump's too big to fail Donald Trump is
going to come back bigger than ever and
he will convince them and they'll write
stories about it and then he'll of
liminal and using a name that isn't his
that too and then the the real estate
magnets the
the the investors in New York City will
say no no no Donald Trump can't fail and
they'll loan him money because he's
created this mythology around himself
and he's doing that successfully for a
certain segment of voters still to this
day so when things don't go right sorry
that keep going when things don't go
right it's not Donald Trump that made
them go wrong it's Congress's fault he's
kicking everything down to Congress but
there are still people who hold out that
many people who rolled out that his is
the voice needed right now stand up to
the president of North Korea stand up to
the world that hasn't you know speaking
you know their opinions now that hasn't
respected the United States stand up to
trade deals that most economists say
they've actually benefited people like
American farmers but they don't see it
that way that you know is there a chance
I mean is there a chance this could turn
out to be a great presidency I think it
depends on who you ask
honestly I I think there's just wildly
differing opinions of Donald Trump but
if you were a supporter of his you will
defend it you will defend a defendant
defend it defend it if you're not you
will take it apart
we'll see what people say in four years
it does he'd get anything done does this
republican-controlled Congress passed
legislation any legislation really major
legislation before the midterms that is
still an open question there is a lot on
their plate if they can't agree on on
health care which they've been running
on repealing now for seven eight years
or do you expect them to agree on tax
reform that's a much more complicated
subject and he's going after bob Corker
he's going after lisa murkowski
he's going after susan collins he's
going after john mccain he will need
their voices and their votes to get any
of these things done
that is unless he suddenly goes to
Democrats and convinces Democrats to get
on board and that is still a big if as
well a couple more questions from people
who are here is magdalena here hope well
anyway magdalena had a great question
she said do you have any advice for a
young woman of color who fears she has
so much to say and contribute to the
public discourse but has no idea how to
get started especially in today's
political and journalistic climate what
do you say because i know we do have a
lot of aren't there some students up
here where are the students they're
being shy but oh my god they could be
back there it makes me want to like go
over there they're over there there's
somewhere we they're over there oh there
you are
thank you um what do you say to do
journalism students who might have
watched what you went through well the
the the young women of color get loud be
out there participate in your local
politics run for office if you want to
run for office there are local positions
that that you can run for get just get
participate in your in your town halls i
have to say it's a really tough climate
we had gretchen carlson on our program
today she's of course the fox news
anchor who sued and successfully sued
saying she was fired because she didn't
respond to roger ailes sexual harassment
you know overtures you look at her
twitter feed and what she gets I don't
know she gets out of bed in the morning
you know what you ignore it yeah yeah
it's a tough climate so what get up and
fight fight for what you believe in it's
not gonna get better if you just say
it's a tough climb and I can't get out
there that's not how it gets better it
comes from a woman who hung out of the
helicopter when she was four
so I think it's duty nobody what I say
to journalism students is it's a tough
business that there's no doubt about
that
especially the TV world it can be hard
to break in but there are so many more
forms of journalism now and there's so
much more opportunity out there there
are digital outlets that have a whole
host of jobs that that didn't exist 5 10
15 20 years ago you don't just have to
go to your local newspaper or to your
local television station you can you can
get on a blog like five thirty eight.com
you can get on a blog like voxcom
there's Politico there's a number of
smaller versions of those there's patch
and then you guys have patches patch
still exists everywhere it I was I was
hoping and you can make your way in
through that and work up the ladder and
just and just refuse to take no for an
answer when it comes to finding a bigger
job and what should journalism students
are any of us learned from this campaign
you were one of the first to say no he
presidential I'm covering him I'm the
only one covering him besides some you
know smaller outlets he could win I I
have to say I said it nya WA having seen
what was happening on the ground
discount him I mean we've declared his
candidacy we declared his candidacy dead
dozens and dozens and dozens of times
we've declared his presidency a failure
a number of times as well and we've said
how could anybody vote for him again if
he doesn't do this his voters won't vote
for him I'll give you this I give you
this as a cautionary tale what is the
one thing that Donald Trump needs to do
to to keep his base guys what's the one
thing so I'm talking to a guy in Ohio
they said go to war
I said build a wall
you could it could be either but go
ahead okay builds a wall we're gonna
take that one and I was talking to a guy
in Ohio and I asked him late in the
campaign why do you like Donald Trump
and the man answered because he is going
to build a wall and I said what if he
doesn't build a wall it's okay I trust
his judgment straight face and and but
that's that's an emblematic of Donald
Trump support there's a trust there that
is that goes beyond his policies they
voted for the man not the not the
positions so don't assume because he did
not do something that those voters won't
go out and vote for him again also he's
defied political gravity so many times
who's to say that that's gonna stop now
David asked has your book been optioned
for a movie and if so would you like to
play you know and no really it has not
been optioned for a movie no because I
still oh well I'm gonna play how do we
feel better play a play but then we
don't have musical you look at the
helicopter
yeah I'm just interested in the
helicopter part you know and that would
be better in a movie that if they're
gonna if you're gonna make a movie I say
make a movie about my parents because
they are fascinating fascinating people
and if you if you buy the book and I
hope you guys buy the book
but the chapter in chapter 6 it's about
my family it is the it's the best
chapter in the book they my parents are
incredible amazing people and the way we
grew up my brother and I it's just wild
it's totally wild well and it sounds
like it set you on the path that you
were able to them my mom was pregnant
with I was hours from giving birth to me
on a breaking news story a shooting in
Los Angeles I mean it's just it's just
ridiculous well no wonder you held up
under the incredible pressure of the
last year I do encourage you to buy the
book
and there will be an opportunity
afterwards to talk to Katie and habit
sign but Katy tur hashtag on return
thank you so much thanks guys
[Applause]